[Musique]
bonjour à tous très heureux de vous
retrouver pour ce nouveau numéro de on
n'est pas sorti de l'auberge alors
aujourd'hui on a décidé de s'intéresser
d'un petit peu plus près un produit
noble de notoriété quasi planétaire et
qui a participé à la réputation de notre
île à travers le monde vous l'aurez
peut-être compris on va parler vanille
et pour ce faire on se trouve qu'ici au
domaine du grand hazier appartenant à la
famille chassagne implanté sur la
commune de sainte suzanne vous allez
voir que l'histoire et la production de
cette orchidée un petit peu particulière
mérite au bas mot qu'on s'intéresse au
moins le temps d'un épisode alors sans
perdre une minute c'est pas
[Musique]
au jour bertrand
bonjour nous sommes très bien toi tu
fais du directeur de l'avvenire alors là
je suis le directeur de l'avvenire qui
se trouve à sainte suzanne sur le
domaine du grand hazier un des plus
vieux domaine de la réunion pour ce
moment c'est super c'est la saison des
fleurs donc on va pouvoir voir moment
voilà comme hong kong ces fameuses
fleurs et puis ensuite on a tout le
procédé de transformation qui se fait
sur place toi tu me vraiment en avant le
procédé artisanal voilà nous les
totalement totalement artisanale a rien
de moderne tout est manuel en plus donc
on va découvrir un petit peu tout ça est
ce que tu pense qu'on peut aller jeter
un petit coup d'oeil sur les plantes et
fleurs à commencer par des bus donc par
la plante on va aller voir les plans de
vanille à quoi ça ressemble et puis on
va voir les fleurs et puis on a quelques
fleurs donc au fessier de t'apprendre à
féconder une fleur de vanille impatient
de m'y mettre voilà allons-y
[Musique]
la vanille n'est pas originaire de la
réunion elle est originaire en fait du
mexique d'accord
alors au mexique c'est une petite
abeille là mais nippone qui féconde les
fleurs et puis parfois aussi un colibri
d'accord alors là ni l'un ni l'autre à
la réunion voilà le problème on a bien
des abeilles à la réunion bien sûr parce
qu'on fait du très bon miel mais nos
abeilles sont juste trop grosse pour
pénétrer à l'intérieur de la fleur et
donc elles peuvent pas faire le boulot
et donc du coup on utilise une technique
bien particulière
alors sauf qu'il a fallu à 2841 pour ken
moi le mieux donc un petit esclave de 12
ans originaire de bellevue à
sainte-suzanne découvre le procédé de
pollinisation manuel les lafleur
lorsqu'elle s'ouvre en fait ne vit
qu'une journée ils vendent mal sera
morte qui fait qu'on ne va on va devoir
passer tous les jours dans la plantation
pendant trois mois à peu près du mois de
septembre au mois de décembre pour
féconder une à une toutes les fleurs qui
vont sortir le matin même ce qui rajoute
au caractère un peu capricieux dans
l'année c'est à dire que même un effet
en amérique les sur le genre
[Musique]
le premier objectif c'est de déchirer ce
qu'on appelle le label donc c'est ce
groupe et à l'inférieur en forme
d'entonnoir les grains de pollen se
situe ici
et de sous on a ici leur style sommes
donc c'est leur langue est stérile qui
protège je vais le soulever la partie
femelle qui est en dessous encore
beaucoup plus petit tu pas si tu arrives
à le voir donc l'opération de fake de
pollinisation consiste donc à soulever
délicatement le reste l'homme et ensuite
on appuie délicatement pour déposer les
grains de pollen
donc on a fait le geste de pollinisation
ça prend 3,4 secondes ont fait qu'on a
plus près 300 fleurs à leurs 3 4
secondes parce que tu habites chine si
on va écarter les trois pétales dessus
tu vas percée dont je laissais faire
[Musique]
des gardes pollens sont partis ces morts
tous ces mots de patois patois
[Musique]
du coup une fois que les neuf mois sont
passés à quoi est-ce qu'on va
reconnaître une gousse qui est prêt à
être récolté alors en fait une gousse de
vanille quand elles arrivent à maturité
elle va s'ouvrir complètement bien sûr
une partie des composés aromatiques va
s'échapper à s'échapper encore allait
récolter juste avant qu'elle soit mûr
mais il faut pas les récoltes et roberte
parce que l'arôme de s'accumulent dans
la boue ce que les deux trois dernières
semaines ce qui fait qu'on va passer
tous les quinze jours dans les
plantations pour cueillir une à une les
gousses en fonction de leur degré de
maturité tard et pas de parler d'un rom
depuis tout à l'heure je commençais à
être impatient de pouvoir
m'imprégner de cette odeur alors pour ça
on va monter dans l'atelier de
préparation cette fois ci on va partir
de la gauche verte comme ça pour voir
tout le procédé très long qu'on va
mettre en place pour arriver au final un
produit de qualité à commencer par le
début c'est parti
[Musique]
on va faire appel l'échaudage de la
vanille on va aller tremper dans l'eau
chaude pour leur permettre de ne plus
ouvrir donc en les tuant au bloc le
processus naturel d'ouverture on arrête
la végétation voilà un arrêt de la
méditation et puis on va permettre à
l'as rome ensuite de se développer donc
là on a mis ça dans un panier on a fait
chauffer l'eau la skip une température
particulière voilà c'est juste de l'eau
chaude on affine non faut pas tout à
fait les mêmes températures en fonction
des communes d'où viennent les vanille
parce que les gousses de saint-philippe
n'ont pas la même consistance l'église
de saint-andré alors on va d'abord aller
vérifier la température
avec tout ça fait très scientifique mais
en fait quand on se penche un petit peu
et vient voir d'ailleurs et qu'on
regarde en dessous
de tout c'est un petit peu plus couleur
locale pour se rendre au pique nique à
dimanche sur la route de
cbh on y est donc là t'as combien
exactement à ça je ne dis pas
sécrété invitation y monte les marches
on va aller tromper une fois on va
remonter retremper une deuxième fois
c'est pour homogénéiser un peu le
la température et la chronomètre est
parti pour trois minutes
[Musique]
on
va les laisser à l'intérieur pendant 24
heures et c'est pendant ces 24 heures
laquelle vont changer de couleur
donc si on veut conserver des goûts sans
faire comme pour les pruneaux ou les
abricots on va laisser chez
ses charges au soleil on y va direct
voilà on va placer nos booth sûr c'est
que les grillages et peluches en train
de découvrir le processus que je me dis
que j'adorais être une gousse de vanille
quoi c'est à dire que tout le monde
prend bien soin de toi tu finis par un
petit bain joueurs sauna ensuite on tend
ruban dans des couvertures tu as droit
une longue sieste et tu finis par un
petit bain de soleil froid ya pire quand
même alors pourquoi est-ce qu'on l'aimé
au soleil ça va laisser chez oui on a
lavé l'évacuation de la flotte deuxième
intérêt du soleil il va faire bronzer
nos goûts ce dernier intéresse du soleil
et qui pour moi est le plus important
c'est le côté assainissant il peut y
avoir des champignons des bactéries qui
traînent sur les gousses à l'extérieur
quinze jours au soleil cinq à six heures
par jour les ultra violets vont dégager
tout ça est ce qui fait que c'est
totalement sain et qu' aucun souci
sanitaire quand on mange de la vanille
quel que soit le pays d'où elle vient
une fois par jour on reprend nos gosses
comme ça on les range eu deux fils
invasive main
[Musique]
donc au bout des 15 jours de passage ou
soleil on poursuit le séchage plus
tranquillement à l'ombre dans le
bâtiment qui est juste à côté
et on valide allons voir ça allons-y
[Musique]
on
dans un monde
c'est bien
[Musique]
tout comme tu disais après quinze jours
de séchage au soleil on va les réserver
dans cette pièce on va terminer a fini
un peu de séchage voilà sinon elle sèche
trop vite et deviennent cassants donc on
va les sécher dans cette dans cette
salle c'est en fait assez choir et on va
placer nos vanille non plus sur des clés
en bois mais sur des clés grillagés pour
que l'air puis circuler librement mais
évidemment qu'on mais n'ont pas le même
calibre au départ on a vu tout à l'heure
entre les mexique où les autres elles
vont passer chez la même vitesse et
notre travail va consister à repérer les
vanille qui sont sèches et celles qui
sont pas encore sèche tu vas faire une
séparation ce moment-là ça c'est
exactement ce qu'est en train de faire
quand un bavoir bonjour quand on
transforme ici 500000 goose parents et
jean cantin qui gère absolument tous les
sens c'est lui alors les 500000 molly
truies en moyenne trois fois ce que ce
qui est passé chez icy repart en séchage
airs triano jusqu'à tant qu'elles soient
sèches donc on fait un million cinq cent
mille manipulation les prenant une à une
dans les vins pendant la saison
la dernière étape consiste alors on va
les mettre dans les malles de maturation
où elles vont pouvoir développer leur
parfum je préparais mon nez
donc là encore continuer un petit peu
assécher une vanille de qualité voilà
les trois critères elle doit être noir
souple peut faire un noeud sans que ça
casse et huileuse voilà le sort restait
une année complète dans la caisse il en
arrive à la fin basse et on arrive dans
la fin donc elle doit être prête à
commercialiser mais est encore une étape
avant la commercialisation s'avère que
le calibrage et la mise en beauce
[Musique]
deux ans il aura fallu quasiment deux
ans entre le moment où pollinisent et
moment on va passer à la dernière étape
quel calibrage et que bertrand a
présenté
avant de les mettre en bottes pourraient
faire encore un dernier geste on va
masse et nos bouches
et oui les enfants de la chanson devrait
incarner j'espère que je me réincarner
rhéobus de manille
alors pourquoi ce geste là tout
simplement parce que l'arôme de la
vanille n'est pas réparties de façon
homogène à l'intérieur de la gauche donc
on répartit la roméo réhydrate le haut
de la gousse ce qui fait qu une gousse
une fois qu'elles étaient massés émises
en bottes on peut les conserver pendant
cinq ans sans problème tu sais pas je
les adore
voilà alors comme j'ai besoin de main
d'oeuvre eh ben je te propose d'aller
calibre et quelques gousses maintien je
n'osais pas tout le demander
[Musique]
et on parcourt qu'est-ce-qui au parcours
moi j'aime à me suis à générac grenoble
j'ai fait mes études à bordeaux donc
j'ai travaillé la viticulture oenologie
à la base et puis je me suis spécialisé
en protection des végétaux il ya eu des
preuves de maladie sur la vanille donc
on m'a demandé d'intervenir pour faire
des recherches sur les maladies de la
vanille et puis de fil en aiguille je
suis tombé amoureux de la vanille de la
réunion donc forcément j'ai su rester et
puis j'ai travaillé pendant un certain
temps une vingtaine d'années dans une
coopérative et c'est là que j'ai vu
qu'ils avaient ce décalage en dix ans va
en gros on reste sur nos acquis pour on
avance plus quoi et pour moi la vanille
c'est pas ça y est plein de choses
encore à découvrir à développer
donc j'ai créé avec quatre associés
l'avenir et en 2009 pour pouvoir mettre
vraiment en application toutes les idées
qu'on avait nous l'idée c'est de
différencier des terroirs entre les
vanille de saint-philippe sainte rose ou
saint-andré et puis ce faisant on a
présenté sa des grands chefs comme
monsieur roellinger et qui ont dit ouais
mais c'est c'est génial ce que vous
faites parce que là on a des notes
différentes et ça c'est ce qui nous
intéresse il ya une dizaine d'années
pour tout le monde quasiment la vanille
c'était has been c'était on gagnait pas
sa vie dedans et puis ce serait comme de
géranium ou certaines zones culture ça
allait disparaître quasiment et voilà
donc nous on est en train de recréer
quelque chose de ré inciter les gens à
produire je t'en remercie pour tous je
te remercie pour cette cette immersion
dans le monde de la vanille réunionnaise
pour ce petit voyage dans le temps aussi
d'ailleurs voilà donc je t'invite à
repartir avec une botte de nos vanille
est comme ça tu pourras après j'apprécie
les je suis pas certain que je vais
capable de lui donner autant d'amour que
toi mais je te promets de faire mon
maximum
fait la guerre voilà moi je repars
travail il ya du mois je vais faire un
petit tour il ya quelque chose à voir
dans quoi aller balle
c'est donc au pied de ce phare l'un des
endroits emblématiques de la commune de
sainte-suzanne que restant ministre
émissions alors vous l'aurez compris la
vanille est un sujet extrêmement basses
qui regroupe des thèmes aussi variés que
l'histoire la science ou l'agriculture
quoi qu'il en soit si vous souhaitez
découvrir ou redécouvrir l'histoire est
peut-être même le futur de cette
orchidée je vous donne l'adresse ça se
passe à la vanille récit sur la commune
de sainte suzanne moi je vous laisse
avec ce magnifique point de vue sur la
côte est de la réunion et on se trouve
très retrouve très vite sur les routes
a plus
[Musique]